pas tous
l'un des plus proches soutiens de
françois fillon est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bruno
retailleau dans ce soit michel grossiord
et merci d'être avec nous vous n'avez
jamais douté en effet jamais flancher un
dans votre fidélité votre appui au
candidat portait apparemment par une
dynamique de fin de campagne sénateur de
la vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat et président du
conseil régional des pays de la loire
vous répondrai au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions
émission de public sénat donc avec l'
agence france presse avec les échos et
radio classique d'abord le programme de
françois fillon n'est-il pas irréaliste
c'est ce que vous demandera jean-francis
pécresse arguments à l'appui vous verrez
ensuite la campagne qui s'achève
dimanche frantel une mauvaise tournure
avec le ton qui monte entre les
principaux candidats
c'est ce que vous demandera nadège que
jack enfin le sénat at il déjà tourné la
page de la gauche ce que vous reproche
notamment votre homologue le président
des sénateurs socialistes didier
guillaume puisque vous refuser
d'examiner le budget présenté par le
gouvernement
voulu répondre et ainsi qu'à mickaël
szames est-ce qui vous interrogera par
ailleurs sur la candidature imminente
des manuels macron et si l'ancien
ministre de l'économie chercher à sa
manière à peser aussi sur la primaire de
la droite et du centre mais d'abord
bruno retailleau une première question
d'actualité
la justice administrative a donc donné
hier son feu vert juridique à l'aéroport
notre dame des landes
chacun doit maintenant respecter la
légalité du projet a répété tout à
l'heure manuel valls mais est ce que
vous croyez vraiment à l'arrivée des crs
et des gendarmes mobiles pourrait
évacuer le site
oui j'y crois d'abord je voudrais
replacer cette question dans un contexte
plus large il faut les reports pourquoi
il le faut parce que la bretagne pays de
la loire nous sommes coude à coude
ailleurs avec jean yves le drian sur ce
sujet là nous sommes en bout du bout de
l'europe voilà avec un fort
développement économique et nous avons
besoin de connexion vous savez que en
vous aviez six jours sur nantes
atlantique les reports actuelle six
jours de saturation en 2015
cinq ans après un peu moins quatre ans
après vous en avez 130 ce n'est pas un
rêve de grandeur des infrastructures
vevo démentiel comme vous avez reproché
aux politiques de tous bords d'ailleurs
mon sens inverse celle inverse parce que
entre la dlp la déclaration d'utilité
publique est aujourd'hui en réalité on
fait beaucoup plus en terme de dynamique
de trafic donc de ce côté ci les choses
ont été confirmés maintenant
l'évacuation les vacations
bien sûr il faut les vacations abella
faubourgs de réseau et croyez bien sûr
il a faut pour deux raisons le président
de république s'est engagé il a dit on
fait un référendum
le référendum nous l'avons gagnée le oui
a gagné avec un verdict clair et net le
peuple s'est exprimé
et nous avons désormais 178 178 décision
de justice qui vont toutes dans le même
sens alors moi je veux bien qu'en france
nous ne soyons plus dans un état de
droit c'est à dire que les tribunaux
parlent pour ne pas être avec des
décisions de justice qui ne serait pas
exécutée je veux bien que ont recours à
la parole du peuple pour lui donner une
gifle c'est à dire pour ne pas exécuter
ce que les gens demandent ce serait
terrible pour la démocratie
ce serait terrible pour l'autorité de
l'état et j'espère je crois encore que
manuel valls a une certaine idée de
l'autorité de l'état
j'espère que le prénom de république à
qui appartient l'ultime décision
décidera de l'évacuer cette attaque est
une zone de non droit où des
journalistes sont attaqués alors brûlé
scientifique des gendarmes et l'ordre ne
vient toujours
je le disais le premier ministre a parlé
du dossier il est sur votre ligne bien
sûr fondamentalement mais il est resté
très flou sur le calendrier il est resté
flou parce que j'imagine que le prévenir
ainsi blick
non j'imagine que le président des
raisons qui sont énormes et les risques
mais on me dit il ya des risques il a
dérisoire est ce qu'il faut c'est des
chanteurs des autorités publiques il ya
le mort de sivens et puis sur place il y
a des gens qui se sont organisés
vraiment avec l'autre jour il ya une
répétition grandeur nature 150 tracteurs
un des pièges des groupes qui sont
formés à l'autodéfense absolument ce
sont des ultraviolets un risque ce sera
bien sûr rien risque mais ce que la
république doit reculer à chaque fois
qu'il ya un risque
est ce qu'on doit céder au chantage non
la violence vient de celles et ceux qui
soutiennent les à dist elle pourrait
venir des as 10 mais j'ai bon espoir
j'espère que ce qui nous donne je parle
d'un certain nombre de personnalités
écologistes des leçons de morale sur la
démocratie et sur l'état de droit
j'espère que si demain l'état engage des
actions pour exécuter les décisions de
justice j'espère évidemment qu'ils se
rendront aux arguments paisible de la
démocratie de l'internaute prend pas le
chemin mais vous avez une idée du nombre
de gendarmes mobiles qu'il faudra
déployer sur le terrain on dit des
centaines publié en 1900 vous savez
combien y avait des gendarmes pour
protéger les chefs d'état qui sont venus
pour la coop 21
il ya plusieurs mois ils étaient plus de
10000 donc une action résolue de l'état
est possible et je pense que si demain
on veut que la zad devienne la base
arrière de toutes les guérillas urbaines
de toutes les oppositions à tous les
projets d'infrastructure qui bloquerait
l'économie française et développement de
la france alors laissons faire ce sera
terrible
vous y croyez encore il ya encore des
obstacles variés encore des recours et
de mangue d'obstacles européens et que
le droit l'environnement souhaite bien
sûr il vous la commission européenne
demande un ultime document c'est de
l'intoxication
j'ai entendu vos confrères il ya moins
de 48 heures d'hier il suffit de
rajouter 100 m à la piste actuelle pour
pouvoir avoir un aéroport qui pourrait
recevoir le trafic mais si c'était ça le
gros sur moi je prends un casque tout de
suite et je mets au volant
dire d'un bulldozer je le fais
évidemment mais c'est de l'intox
malheureusement alors après cette
première question d'actualité la
première partie de l'épreuve de vérité
avec jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique
bonsoir jean français bonsoir michel
bonsoir bruno retailleau bonsoir je
mendie pécresse est ce que le projet de
votre candidat françois fillon n'est pas
au fond le plus et le plus irréaliste de
tous les projets des candidats de la
droite à la primaire c'est au contraire
le plus réaliste pour redresser la
france
ça fait 30 ans que les hommes politiques
français de gauche et de droite patauge
dans des demi-mesures ça fait 30 ans
qu'aucune majorité ne se 6 et succéder à
elle-même ça fait 30 ans que la france
dégringole
ce que françois fillon veut faire c'est
en réalité ce que beaucoup de
gouvernements européens ont eu le
courage de faire et cela leur a permis
d'ailleurs de redresser leur pays
donc on va le détailler un peu vous
proposer la suppression de cinq cent
mille postes de fonctionnaires en cinq
ans ce qui signifie que globalement vous
n'embaucherait pas de fonctionnaires
pendant toute la durée du quinquennat
est ce que c'est réaliste ça parce que
votre calcul est faux pour deux raisons
c'est celui aussi de certains des
opposants françois fillon fillon ont
bien l'intention de téléphoner iront
écouter l'argument tu es tellement qu'il
faudrait que je m'y attendais ce que
propose d'abord vous savez qu'on a plus
de 5 millions 500 mille fonctionnaires
on a la fonction publique la plus
nombreuse et dieu sait si les
fonctionnaires ce sont des gens
parfaitement respectable mais ils vivent
finalement une forme de paupérisation
parce que le nombre fait que la nation
ne peut pas et on est obligé d'ailleurs
de d'emprunter pour payer des salaires
bien roulé ou les retraites
ce que je veux dire c'est que deux
choses françois fillon propose de passer
à 39 heures pour la fonction publique
ça fait une quantité de travail vous
savez que de plus beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus puisque quand je suis arrivé dans
ma région
finalement je suis aperçu que les
collaborateurs travailler moins de 35
heures et pour beaucoup de collectivités
c'est le 39 heures ça fait une masse si
j'ose dire
deux heures de travail supplémentaires
et ensuite on oublie de dire qu'il ya à
peu près un million de fonctionnaires
qui partiront dans les cinq prochaines
années alors cinq cent mille
fonctionnaires devraient plutôt 600
mille cent vingt mille par an à peu près
170 millions des plus primés les
contractuels
les contractuels c'est de l'ordre d'un
million ça veut dire que on ne remplace
pas un départ sur deux à la retraite
c'est parfaitement faisable c'est
parfaitement faisable d'autant plus qu
encore une fois on a une fonction
publique qui est une de celles qui la
plus nombreuse d'europe et des pays
européens comme l'allemagne qui en ont
beaucoup moins que nous ont des services
publics qui sont aussi très performant
nous sommes attachés au service public
mais je pense qu'il faut réorganiser le
travail de la fonction publique les
faire travailler plus ça coûte cher et
l'institut montaigne a calculé que par
exemple faire passer le temps de travail
dans la fonction publique de 35 à 39
heures ça vous coûterait 15 milliards
d'euros comment est-ce que vous financez
cela ce que propose françois fillon
c'est de proposer qu'une partie le
passage de 35 d'abord tout le monde pour
le même salaire doit travailler 35
heures quand ceux qui travaillent 32
heures ils sont payés pour 35 heures
première chose
deuxième chose ce que propose françois
fillon c'est que on puisse passer avec
une rémunération de 37 eur et cueilli
une négociation qui puisse s'engager
pour que l'on puisse accompagner les
carrières dans la fonction publique pour
que lorsque vous rentrez à 20 ans dans
une case
vous ne sachiez pas à 35 ou 37 ou
quarante ans plus tard à quel autre cas
vous serez vous pourriez avoir une
fluidité une perspective professionnelle
beaucoup plus rapide c'est des
négociations mais si on ne le fait pas
d'autres pays l'ont fait si on ne le
fait pas je pense que on ne pourra pas
faire des économies qui seront
significatives et ses cinq cent mille
postes ou est-ce que vous les supprimez
précisément parce que vous ne l'avez pas
dit françois fillon ne dit pas où est ce
que vous les supprimez dans quelles
fonctions tant les on les supprime
en dehors des ministères régaliens ans
les supprime
on ne supprime pas dans la police on les
supprime pas un journal murray ni non
plus dans l'armée et du miel ils n'ont
plus dans les hôpitaux
l'exercice est difficile mais vous savez
que les hôpitaux les hôpitaux ont été
totalement si j'ose dire
désorganisé par les 35 heures ça se sait
c'est de notoriété publique
voilà donc je pense que de ce point de
vue il est évidemment pour l'éducation
nationale est-ce que vous pensez que
l'école en france aujourd'hui va mieux
avec un peu plus de 50000 reçoit lens
était engagé il le fera pas totalement à
recruter 60 milles mais on voit bien que
dans notre système jean-francis pécresse
que tout n'est pas une question de
moyens parce que quand un système va mal
plus vous rajoutez des moyens et moins
vous avez de résultats est aujourd'hui
l'école
vous pouvez si vous ne changez pas que
ce soit sur la pédagogie ou sur un
certain nombre d' approche pour donner
plus de liberté et d'autonomie
eh bien vous ne réglerez pas le problème
de ces jeunes qui par milliers des
dizaines de milliers quittent le système
scolaire sans savoir lire compte et
c'est tous les ans ce qui veut dire en
creux que vous souffrez aimerait bien
des postes dans l'éducation si françois
fillon était et est élu président de la
république à partir de mai 2010 est
absolument
ça n'est pas une approche de gauche vous
a pas approchés ça ne va pas comment
dirais-je surprise exact merci merci
merci et c'est maintenant on a déjoué
jake de l'agencé france presse qui nous
rejoint bruno retailleau l'épreuve de
vérité avec life fille bonsoir labège
est vous soit michel émond soir monsieur
retailleau bon ce bonhomme alors la
compagnie est ce qu'on peut dire qu'elle
prend une mauvaise tournure
non mais vous savez nous la droite c'est
pas notre culture un le primaire moi je
trouve ces primaires ce n'est pas de
votre cuisse et shayers culture c'est la
première fois qu'on fait une primaire
c'est une compétition compétition entre
des hommes une femme compétition entre
des tempéraments des caractères et sont
forts c'est normal et puis les
compétitions avec des idées des projets
enfin les esprits s'échauffent l'instant
fauzy qui critiquent juppé juppé qui
critiquent fillon fillon qui critiquent
sarkozy ont marqué tout le monde en
prend pour son grade comme ça oui mais
ça reste franchement ça reste dans les
limites du raisonnable et si c'est
limite est franchie nous avons la haute
saône et dans une compétition mais bien
sûr bon bien sûr évidemment vous le
savez bien et est le deuxième débat il
aura lieu il a eu lieu par dont le
deuxième débat il était plus sportif que
le premier on peut dire ça comme ça
le troisième qui aura lieu rue donc lieu
jeudi soir vous en attendez quoi
j'en attends de la clarté voilà ce que
veulent les français se sont pas des
chicayas vous avez parfaitement raison
il ne faut pas s'abaisser justement à
ces querelles de caniveau à ces chorales
de cour de récréation
les français ont besoin de savoir parce
que moi je pense profondément que en
la france va avoir rendez vous avec son
histoire en clair la france est en train
de dégringoler
on peut comparer notre pays chômage
déficit endettement etc avec les autres
pays européens nous dégringolons donc on
a rendez vous avec notre histoire parce
que si on ne reprend pas la maîtrise
notre destin est bien là derrière le
match sera une glissade et je pense que
il faut le sérieux et les candidats tous
les candidats doivent le sérieux aux
français en exprimant peu comme ça que
vous voudrez arij réagi à droite comme à
gauche d'ailleurs candidat il dira lui
aussi pour prendre notre destin en main
et puis non non non non non parce que là
on va attendre vous rendez compte on va
atteindre 100% de la dette par rapport à
la richesse nationale les taux vont
commencer à augmenter et donc il va y
avoir un mécanisme de boules de neige
qui peut être fatale vraiment pour
l'économie française
donc non je pense que l'heure est grave
il faut prendre des mesures qui soient
des mesures des vraies mesures
c'est pour ça que il faut pas des encore
une fois dès 2000 projet de réforme il
faut dans ce cas avant de passer à la
présidentielle s'en posera plus tard et
donc on sait que le troisième débat aura
lieu jeudi
ensuite après ce débat faudra bien se
rassembler et c'est vrai qu'on a quand
même un petit peu des doutes parce que
si je lis bien françois fillon alors
alain juppé seclin tunisie il dit juppé
il suffit pas de bomber le torse et j'en
passe et des meilleurs enfin tabac parmi
les meilleurs il ya la déclaration
aujourd'hui de jean françois copé qui
ciblent directement françois fillon vous
l'avez déjà il part d'une imposture
fillon à une scission bigouden
d'ambiguïté puisque ton qu'on le disait
tout à l'heure il a été au pouvoir une
imposture que re comment réagissez vous
à ce mot de jean françois copé je ne
tombe pas dans ce genre de travers je
pense que les français attendent autre
chose que ce genre de petite phrase et
je pense que le débat doit rester dit
voilà il doit rester digne et je pense
très frais
très franchement si françois fillon a
gagné les deux débats c'est par sa
dignité et je pense parce que vous
pensez qu'il a gagné parce que sont les
sondages vous l'avenir les sondages mais
quand même ça veut dire quelque chose
des sondages de temps en temps un quand
fillon monte on dirait on en parlera
aussi tout à l'heure bon si vous voulez
soulage s'est pas fait cesser juppé qui
avait gagné les deux les deux les deux
premiers débats à risques qui vont en
tout cas c'est un
en tout cas ce qui est clair vous savez
très bien moi je me méfie des sondages
ce qui est important c'est devant
l'estrade les dynamiques non mais ce
sont ces la dynamique c'est toujours la
même chose c'est pas le niveau absolu
que donne aux sondages c'est vraiment ce
que les série de sondages plusieurs
sondages ajoutés les uns aux autres
donnent comme dynamique et vous savez
très bien que la dynamique de françois
fillon date précisément du premier débat
pourquoi parce que les les français ont
découvert un homme qui est sincère qui
est droit et qui a une hauteur de vue et
qui ne succombent pas justement à la
tentation des petits ajustements la
dynamique pour monsieur fillon est
excellente on le voit jour après jour
dans tous les sondages parce qu'ils sont
attendus d'ailleurs qui pourrait
effectivement annoncé un c'est ce qu'on
attend de la fourchette
c'est ce qu'on nous dit est donc c'est
une surprise mais vous voilà qu'est ce
que vous avez urbains non ce n'est pas
une surprise
évidemment non j'ai dit simplement
depuis plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines que françois fillon serait la
surprise du premier tour des primaires
pourquoi parce que justement je pense
qu'il à cette hauteur de vue il a ce
calme cette sérénité une constance et
surtout parce que je pense qu'il est la
bonne synthèse entre d'un côté le
volontarisme la détermination de nicolas
sarkozy mais sans le côté trop clivant
et en même temps la sérénité d'alajou
trêve il prend des points acquis à juppé
ou à sarkozy je pense qu'il en prend aux
deux je pense qu'il en prend aussi à
bruno le maire je pense qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui il ya des électeurs des
français qui ne savaient pas comment
voter qui commencent à s'intéresser tout
juste à la primaire vous savez les
sondeurs et ils nous font le coup à
chaque fois comme par hasard les choses
se resserrent toujours toujours la
dernière seconde
bon voilà à trop les sondages parce que
je suis sûr que les critiques
ils sont réglables et moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que la fraude les sondeurs
dans une difficulté qu'il faut quand
même pas je veux dire négliger c'est
qu'on n'a jamais sont dénoncés
la primaire elle n'a jamais eu lieu on
connaît quoi d'accord électoral ne
connaît pas le corps électeurs et en
plus il ya beaucoup de zapping dans
l'est des électeurs de droite à gauche
ou gauche à droite d'habitude et là
c'est dans une même famille donc cette
fluidité ce zapping là est encore plus
important mais c'est clair qu'il ya une
dynamique
je vais vous dire deux ou trois exemples
moi je suis françois fillon sur un
certain nombre de manifestations l'autre
jour c'était la vendée on avait
pratiquement 1500 personnes
les réseaux sociaux ils dominent
largement et je vais vous annoncer ce
soir que il fait son grand meeting c'est
au palais des congrès voilà vendredi et
bien la salle est tellement plein qui va
falloir louer une autre salle pour
pouvoir
comment dirais-je faire en sorte que
tout le monde tout le monde en plus tout
le monde profitera ce partage et on est
en train de travail est justement sur le
partage puisqu'il n'a pas le don
d'ubiquité encore monsieur fillon se
présente un petit peu comme le monsieur
propre
lui il n'a pas été condamné suivez mon
regard comme monsieur juppé il n'a pas
été mise en examen
suivez mon regard comme monsieur sarkozy
il a raison de jouer sur ces thèmes là
non en tout cas il a raison d'affirmer
que les hommes politiques doivent être
exemplaires doivent être droit honnête
pourquoi parce qu'on voit bien ce qu'on
appelle le populisme
on voit bien ce doute profond dans
toutes les démocraties occidentales on
voit que il ya une perte de confiance
entre les peuples et ceux qui sont
censés les représenter
les élus évidemment si vous avez des
affaires à répétition ça pose des
problèmes donc franchement il a l'air de
dire qu'il ya des candidats qui sont
disqualifiés absolument pas c'est
absolument faux moi je me c'est comme ça
je comprends en faut il
non mais il a il donne un principe
général est ce que on peut donner un
principe qui serait inverse
il serait bon que les hommes politiques
et des problèmes avec la justice pour
pouvoir se présenter ou non voilà donc
ils réaffirment quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du bon sens c'est un principe
qui ne vise personne
et il faut que chacun s'applique à être
exemplaire dans son domaine le vote
fillon vous dirais que c'est plutôt un
vote pour ou à votre contre les livres
les électeurs qui vont s'ils retirent je
vais aller voter fillon pourquoi qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils ne veulent plus de
sarkozy ils ne veulent plus d'eux ils
veulent pas encore de juppé ils ne
veulent pas de jupe et elle résume à
trois points cercle pourquoi pas sion
fillon c'est la ligne droite il n'y a
pas de coup de volant à droite n'y a pas
de coup de volant à gauche
il ya un cap il est constant c'est
vraiment avec jacques vision pour vous
êtes un vote de conviction dès le
premier tour il faut voter pour ses
convictions parce que il ya la primaire
et demain il y aura la présidentielle et
je pense que françois fillon est le
mieux à même à la fois de battre la
gauche est de battre le front national
parce qu'il a un projet qui est un
projet vraiment qui correspond à l'adn
de la droite
voilà sur la liberté sur l'autorité sans
oublier les valeurs
voilà c'est pas quelqu'un qui considère
que la droite c'est la gauche sans les
35 heures ça c'est l'adn de l'egypte et
c'est ce que voulait dire la face non
pas du tout pas du tout mais à chaque
fois vous me ramener à tel ou tel moi
j'essaie d'exprimer des principes et
voilà je pense que fillon c'est un cap
une boussole
j'en parle d'autant mieux que ce
quinquennat actuel a commencé avec le
pédalo se termine avec le titanic
heureusement il ya vendée globe enfin
l'or ainsi de voter spectateurs ainsi le
vendée globe mais il faut nous évoluons
dans la ville faut une boussole il faut
un cap
les françois villon il il a ce cap voilà
et je voudrais enfin pour le vendée
globe au sua
et ben oui c'est entendu comme vous avez
écouté monsieur jean pierre raffarin ce
matin qui a dit un joli que fillon est
dans le piège la vème république parce
qu'il a été premier ministre de sarkozy
il ne peut pas battre monsieur sarkozy
parce que sarkozy est président alors
qu'est ce que vous dites est monsieur
raffarin
je lui dis pas failli ok y'a pas de
sujet à dire on me renvoyait mais non
mais il n'y a pas de loi n'y a pas de
loin tangi vous le savez bien c'est les
français qui font les élections c'est
pas des lois qui sont écrites dans des
livres au préalable c'est une évidence
et je crois que françois fillon est en
train de démontrer que cette loi
n'existe pas en réalité ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est l'homme qui a la bonne
hauteur de vue qui a les convictions et
qui aura la constance d'appliquer un
vrai projet et pas des demi mesures
parce que la france a besoin de ce
projet merci mais je dernière partie de
preuves par 3 maintenant avec mickaël
zeze de public sénat qui nous rejoint
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bruneau
retailleau en somme qu'un sms
est ce que le sénat a déjà tourné la
page de la gauche non jeu on a en
aimerait bien vous savez pas ce que je
pense que ce quinquennat est un
quinquennat douloureux pour la france et
pour les français bien sûr mais c'est
l'échec sur tous les plans garder sur le
chômage on nous avait dit inversion de
la courbe
on a plus six cent mille chômeurs de
plus on nous avait dit l'endettement
sera jugulé on aura bientôt on est à
plus de 98% bientôt à 100 % de la
richesse nationale
le déficit voilà on nous avait dit non
mais dès 2017 les choses qu'on contenu
c'est faux donc et sur les impôts c'est
pareil même d'ailleurs la rapporteure
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale dit
qu'il y aura les français vont payer
encore plus d'impôts aux entreprises et
ménages confondues c'est l'échelle votre
réponse ce soir sur un fait examinerez
vous ou pas le projet de loi de finances
au sénat nous en déciderons demain matin
première chose
ce projet de loi de finances a été
depuis des jours et des jours travaillés
par la commission des finances et
notamment par le rapporteur général du
budget albéric de montgolfier et demain
matin nous ferons le point nous avons
deux hypothèses où nous le rejetons
parce que il posait problème
c'est une mascarade sensée que si il a
été examiné mais longuement des heures
et vous n'imaginez pas vous avez un
spécialiste
non mais vous savez parfaitement que le
travail essentiel au sénat c'est un
travail qui se fait et vous dire les
commissions mais c'est le travail
essentiel attendait et si vous voulez le
bouquet
posez ici sur cette table un document
qui fait des centimètres et cm
d'épaisseur ça c'est la première
hypothèse on va jusqu'à la première
partie et on leur jette aux premières
parties mais quel est le problème
justement il n'est pas question que le
gouvernement demande au sénat de lui
garantir ce que le haut conseil finances
publiques a dénoncé on a non pas pour la
première fois mais on a un budget qui
est un enfumage qui est un budget
électoral un budget de campagne
un budget qui est tellement un sincère
que vous au lait dans ce budget 25
milliards d'euros de dépenses qui
s'appliqueront après 2017
c'est terrible pour vous ça vous voulez
pas l'examiner m'a écouté d'ores et déjà
quelle que soit la décision enfin on
attend la décision demain bruno
retailleau mais déjà le président des
sénateurs socialistes je disais tout à
l'heure didier guillaume s'adresse à
vous directement et il va jusqu'à
évoquer une forfaiture
mon cher bruno la responsabilité que tu
as comme président du groupe l'est
républicain laisse de côté la
présidentielle laisse de côté la
primaire de la droite et du centre
et dis toi bien que l'acte que vous
allez commettre là la forfaiture que
vous allez commettre en ne faisant pas
travailler le sénat où nous les français
dans un populisme qui peut aller très
très loin parce que les parlementaires
ne font rien ne travaille pas au moment
où le rôle essentiel d'un parlementaire
de sénateur c'est de voter la loi et
c'est de voter le budget si tu as du
pouvoir dans le groupe politique
si tu as vraiment si tu as envie de
porter de senna très haut
alors vas-y indique que nous allons
débattre sur le budget il est encore
temps doivent encore une semaine
mon cher bruno tu as entre les mains je
pense une partie de l'avenir du sénat tu
as entre les mains vraiment la façon de
montrer si les élus sont responsables
ou pas bruno tu as entre les mains
l'avenir d'un débat politique serein
alors votre réponse
c'est sympathique de la part de jean
guillaume de me donner autant de pouvoir
ils parlent de forfaiture
moi je pourrais parler de forfaiture
quand un président république en se
confiant des journalistes d'ailleurs
et sur votre actionnaire chose deuxième
chose sur le budget moi je me situe pas
ni par rapport à didier guillaume que je
respecte
évidemment je me situe par rapport aux
français ce qu'on nous demande là c'est
de voter un budget truc est mensonger
comme jamais un budget ne l'a été à vous
placer automne jamais l'avis du sénat il
le dit vous allez affaiblir ce n'est ce
qui affaiblit la parole publique
c'est un théâtre d'ombrés où on discute
de choses qui sont totalement irréel
totalement truquée davance quand vous
avez didier migaud qui préside le kit à
l'époque était un député socialiste
on va pas dire que didier migaud est un
suppôt de la droite didier migaud
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il n'a cessé de
répéter que ce budget est insincère que
la partie recettes avaient été
surestimées que la partie à cause des
surestimations notamment de la
croissance qu'au bout de la patience
pour dépenses mais non mais vous en
décembre
par contre il faut dire que vous dit la
première elle s'est invitée chez vous et
vous mr le problème de la primaire n'a
rien à voir avec ok on a un président de
république et on a un gouvernement qui
tente de nous faire avaler ce qui
ressemble à un tract de prévisions du
budget michael crs
non je veux dire pourquoi non on ne peut
pas et vous savez parfaitement parce que
l'article 40 qui nous interdit de créer
des charges supplémentaires ou qui nous
interdit d'enlever des recettes c'est le
parlementarisme rationnalisé de la vème
république et par conséquent avec cet
article là les parlementaires sont
empêchés de construire un vrai contre
burnley
on ne peut pas le faire ou non
retailleau emmanuel macron va se porter
candidat demain il va l'annoncer aux
alentours de 10h30
est ce que ça peut peser dans le scrutin
à droite d'abord ce que je veux dire
c'est que le fait même que cet ancien
ministre ancien conseiller très proche
de françois hollande songe à se
présenter
signe les chèques bien sûr du président
de république
ça c'est une évidence et je crois que il
veut faire coup double il veut d'abord
sur sa gauche empêché le président
république comme d'autres
de se représenter et ils voudraient
aussi sur sa droite ou le centre capter
l'électorat de françois bayrou de
françois du ni droite ni gauche
alors on a parlé beaucoup de la primaire
au cours de cette émission vous n'avez
jamais perdu le sourire
je vais vous le rendre encore plus
radieux peut-être puisqu'il ya ce
sondage qui vient de tomber pour le site
atlantico bruno retailleau qui montrent
une forte hausse de françois fillon +10
points et qui serait donc en fait au
premier tour en coucou à coude avec
nicolas sarkozy et il l'emporterait au
second aussi bien face à alain juppé
quel ancien chef de l'état comment est
ce que vous réagissez est ce que c'est
un sondage donc les images sont pas les
suffrages je réagis comme françois
pourrait faire c'est à dire avec la tête
froide
en tout cas j'ai une certitude c'est que
ce sera la surprise je l' ai déjà dit
écrit a déjà plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs jours et que quel que soit
celui qui sera contre lui au deuxième
tour soit nicolas sarkozy soit alain
juppé yb altra l'un ou l'autre voilà il
sera donc vainqueur voilà et je pense
que dimanche il sera qualifié pour le
deuxième tour parce que le deuxième tour
en quoi le premier tour les français
devront faire un choix qui d'abord un
choix de conviction
voilà et c'est ce qu'il faut leur dire
rien n'est fait rien n'est joué
les français sont un peuple libre eh
bien ils doivent prendre cette liberté
et voter pour le candidat de leur choix
avec de vraies réformes pour redresser
la france
vous n'avez jamais douté de votre
champion m'a écouté j'ai dû non il a
toujours été vraiment à kate est
catégorique sur le thème je serai au
second tour mais vous est ce que vous
avez eu des moments de doute est ce qu
il a pu vous réconforter
certainement il a toujours été déterminé
franchement il m'a étonné parce que vous
avez quand les sondages le plaçaient
très très bas vous 4e quatrième homme
d'ailleurs il n'a jamais douté
je pense qu'il a travaillé et on le voit
bien dans un débat le fait de travailler
ça permet de surclasser finalement les
concurrents ça permet d'avoir une
aisance et ça permet finalement d'avoir
pour les français les meilleures
garanties pour que la france puisse se
relever enfin merci merci michael merci
bruno retailleau la semaine prochaine
c'est gérard larcher le président du
sénat qui sera votre place donc dans
l'antre de tours qui s'annonce
passionnant de cette primaire bonsoir à
tous et à très vite
m